[Music]
thank you so before we get started um I
want to ask you a question so uh think
back the first time you actually used
python so think back to that time when
you were introduced to Python and when
you first saw it and got excited about
using the language and think about like
how many years ago that is so uh if you
have that in your mind now I want
everybody to stand
up
and
if this was like within a year you can
sit down so if it was two years you can
sit
down
three
four
five
six 7
eight oo we're getting close so um for
the people who are not seeing the
audience there's about two four 6 8 10
10 and a half no he's sitting 10 people
still
standing um so
11 oo 12 so there's two people still
standing so so how many years have you
been using python uh 13 13 cool and you
20 so I'm 27 so
uh thank you you can ALS yeah you're
already
sitting so this talk is about py script
so I'll first introduce you to py script
what it is and um then I'll explain how
I used it to develop some applications
on top of it that will give you an idea
of what biscript is and how powerful it
can be to write your own python
applications in the
browser so my history is I'm originally
Dutch so I think you figured that out
from the introduction but also the suit
uh Americans really love that when uh I
do presentations and I show something
that is Dutch it's part of your culture
and I grew up in the Netherlands I did
my computer science in Amsterdam I did a
PhD in laa on a programming language
which came out around the same time as
python uh both start with a P nobody
heard of my language sadly uh so I
surrendered to
uh to Guido's uh dominance
here it was called Procol um nobody
heard of it uh it was a distributed
language using a protocols so you can
write uh modern applications that we the
problems we solve today we solved 30
years ago um so we were way ahead of our
time with that particular language
python is much more applicable uh
practical because it solved the problem
at that moment in time which was like
how do I script applications together
and how do I take data and transform it
into something
else um so I I very much subject to
Guido actually we there was a conference
in the US at some point where uh there
was a competition and the team from
Google was always winning uh this was
about facts about computer science and I
was working at IBM at that time and we
signed up for this competition as well
and I practice like like mad and I
actually beat Guido's team so I beat him
there I had my revenge uh but now I'm
using python again
so so I worked at technical companies
I've worked at finance companies and
they all have the same problem we have a
lot of data we want to transfer it into
something else and then do something
with it and whether you work in Google
or Uber or you work at JP Morgan or Bank
of America the problem Remains the Same
is like we we try to solve the same kind
of problem it's a different culture
different environment different
recognition that you get as an
engineer but it's fun to see those
different kinds so my job at JP Morgan
is ending this year and next year I'll
be doing py script a lot so what is py
script so we have uh uh browser
applications everybody knows that right
so they have different kinds of browsers
they have what's called a Dom which is a
doc document object model which you
normally describe
uh the contents off using HTML so this a
declarative language for saying like I
have a box and inside I have text and
that is then interpreted by the browser
to render a document to the user uh you
have Dynamic code that can run that's
called
JavaScript um we all agree that
JavaScript is a horrible language um it
has all kinds of like quirkiness that
python does not have python is much more
elegant
but this is the state-of-the-art that we
have now recently a technology came out
that is called Web
assembly and uh the advantage of web
assembly is that it's like a bridge to
the operating environment of inside the
browser that allows you to compile other
languages to the browser environment and
in particular languages that are based
on C or applications that are based on C
compile really well to this and then can
run inside the browser so that
includes a platform called pyite which
is the
cpython um runtime the the cpython that
we all know and love with which you can
do pandas and met blot lip and do data
analytics that is written in C and all
the extensions are C libraries so you
can easily compile this using the web
assembly stack I say easily but U it's
an engineering effort but uh you can
compile that to that stack and then all
the browsers these days support that
particular uh execution model so with
that you can write python applications
in the browser and that is already done
with something called uh Jupiter light
so if you have Jupiter notebooks they
run in the browser they're implemented
in JavaScript so all the UI you see
there is is actually traditional HTML
and JavaScript like on the right but
when you execute a shell there actually
uh command sent to a worker which runs
remote on a on a kernel as we call
it and with Jupiter light you can
actually run this in the browser without
leaving the send box of the browser you
don't have to go to server the kernel
can run inside the browser and so this
allows you to distribute applications a
lot easier without having the
requirement of having a kernel setup as
well and having to pay for cloud
services and
whatever so that is how pyite is already
used Us in Jupiter light but with py
script this is almost standardized so it
makes it a lot easier for you to write
your own applications like jupit light
on top of the same stack so biscript
comes with it's basically a yeah a
packaging mechanism so it it it bundles
up everything you need from pite or from
micropython which is an alternative
implementation of
python and then uh it makes it a lot
easier to employer applications this way
so I built three applications just to
try it out first I got intrigued by P
script I said I want to try it out and
write some stuff so that is microlog I
will give a demo of that and then I
started by
building um a spreadsheet in Python so
python in Excel came out who has heard
of python in
Excel so I thought python in Excel
that's for losers I want to do excel in
Python right flip it
around so that's what I tried building
so I said like I'm going to build all of
excel into python write it in Python run
it in the browser in Excel not not excel
in the browser and see how far I got so
those uh three things I built ltk is
actually the the UI library that I use
to build this spreadsheet
in and you can do the same thing so you
can say like I'll give you three
examples of applications that I built
but you can build your own application
in Python the way it is what today you
import numpy um pandas whatever you do
that can be packaged up and run inside
the browser so you can distribute your
applications without having to require
installation of python at all so this is
just clicking on the link right and it
runs so that is the goal for today is to
give you inspiration that you can do
this
yourself and the technology you use here
here is this bridge between web assembly
and JavaScript where you can find out
what's in the Dom right now so you can
locate elements you can register for
events so events come back or you can
make changes to the Dom so you say like
um I find an object and I change the
text or I add a new element to the T so
this is how you build up your
application in that
way so ltk which I will demo and
uh by she
and microlog all use that functionality
so there's no more JavaScript involved
in fact there is because we're doing all
the operations here in Python but they
could send over this bridge to the
JavaScript runtime that then operates
Dum for us but the amount of code that
we need on the Dum side the JavaScript
is very
minimal so if you want to try out I
would recommend you go to biscript
Doom uh it's a pseudo development
environment like poor men's IDE if you
look at it uh you get a treeview here
with files you get an editor and then
you have a run simulation and this is
very easy to get familiarized with the
capabilities of biscript so you you can
try things out this is like a sendbox
environment and what HTML looks like in
that environment is you import three
basically three Technologies so one is p
script itself so it gets boot wrapped by
importing some JavaScript
library and that one can then start
detecting scripts in your language so it
will detect like the script language of
type
pi and type pi means it starts pyodide
so remember those two operating
environments that we have pite and
micropython so in my HTML I can
indicate what python VM to run my python
script in and then I have an option this
is an optional um I can have some helper
functions that I can call for my python
so I can decide what to put in Python
and what in JavaScript and that is
specifically for performance related
things like if you do very heavy drawing
in the in the Dom if you go back to that
link here this is an expensive
communication so this is between two
different operating environments and
there's transformation of the data
happening and each call may be like a
millisecond
so that doesn't sound like much but if
you do a lot of interesting drawing and
you do a thousand calls that is a
second and that no longer works so this
particular application here I I try to
estimate how long it takes I do a
benchmarking of the
execution of that pipeline basically
back and forth and I do some
optimizations here to make it like run
faster so for that you need JavaScript
but in 99 % of the cases you won't need
that um so you can write applications
like this so this is written in Python
this application is a like six
tabs and it shows you a UI here on the
left and then I have the code on the
right that draws
this so ltk is the little toolkit and
it's
named couple people have already asked
me like what's the name come from so it
comes from that PhD research from 30
years ago where I had a little language
little toolkit so it came back in the
same name so there's no real meaning
there
um so on the left you see a custom
widget the the one in The Orange Box
which is defined here on the right it
says vbox in it with an image and a text
so it's a very declarative way
of indirectly making Dom operations so
imagine that these statements when they
execute they go over this communication
channel to to JavaScript and operate on
the Dom so in this case it adds new
widgets new Dom
elements and you can do styling so the
three kinds of ways so you can do CSS
operations you can
set uh a class or you can do everything
external so there still um choice is not
good in Python but there is some choice
that is actually required here but
sometimes you want to be very
direct you want to set things directly
on the widgets but often you want to
take that out and have different themes
for instance dark and light themes so
you need some choices at certain
times so this is another example this
creates a couple widgets on the left and
on the right it's you can zoom in you
can see it creates a radio group with
two elements in it a span and a label
and it has a radio
button for MPI and pyite so if you go to
the live version of this one you can
actually click uh in that thing and it
will switch running either on
micropython or on um on the pyite
version and you can set event handlers
like I mentioned before um so you can
say on change you can call set runtime
and what does set runtime do it actually
reloads the page and chooses the Run
time so again this is like very small
amount of code the whole implementation
of ltk is about 600 lines and that's it
all python
so it's not that hard to understand what
is going on inside of this it's also
open source so you can just look at it
yourself but performance is key right so
I mentioned why we had two different run
times why do we have two different run
times why
why do you have pyite and
micropython so the trade-off with these
two environments is yeah basically space
over time so micropython was developed
for embedded devices and the entire
implementation of the runtime is about
240k and I measured the size of this
picture if you do a screenshot in PNG
it's it's more so it's just like so it's
a really tiny uh runtime for
python so that makes startup really fast
as
well but there's limitations you can't
run things like pandas you can't run
things like met plot lip so why is it
relevant to have these two different
environments so you can use one for like
the startup of your application for
rendering the UI and getting the first
time to render or the first time to
interaction is very important for web
applications and they can have a worker
thread that in the background runs on
pyodide that can do the the heavy lify
for you like jupyter notebook does with
the
kernel so I care a lot about performance
this is like I spent probably more than
half of the time that I built ltk and
and Pie sheets uh thinking about like
how can I make it faster and how can I
make it uh start up really
quick and if you put this into numbers
like um if you start up microp python
that's around 100 milliseconds so it's
0.1
second and there's this theory that
people can't notice anything within 200
milliseconds that's about how our brain
anything less than 200 milliseconds you
don't care about in in user
interaction uh starting a pyodide takes
about two seconds and this you actually
notice so if the first thing that you do
to render your page is to wait for
python to start up and it takes two
seconds people are going to notice so
you have to do all kinds of magic to
make your application appear to start up
faster but it will never do anything in
the first two seconds and if you include
pandas for instance that takes about six
seconds to get that all bootstrapped so
we need a faster way to get yeah this
delivered to the user and the golden
standard for me is uh Google
Sheets and if you look at it and if you
really an like how it's how it's
launching it it launches within a second
and everything is rendered but it does
that incrementally so it brings up the
UI first and then this and then this and
it and it comes up like and Engineers
have spent hours and days and
months and I think you can get promoted
at Google if you make this 10
milliseconds faster uh this is how
important that is over the the large
number of uh instances that people uh
actually run
this so worrying about startup time in
your application is critical and
especially for web applications that's
the
summary so I built this one you can see
uh it runs this is The Benchmark I
showed earlier so if you do this in
micropython and you measure the startup
time I couldn't even measure it it it
like it it it jumped up and it ran
immediately um but then it runs for
about 6.7 times so so so micropython
starts up really fast but it's actually
running
slower pyite starts up slower but it
runs faster so these are like confusing
trade-offs that you have to
manage and think about if you're
launching your
application so ltk takes care of that
there's a um a debugger that will show
you that helps you with analyzing like
the performance there but this is my
goal so I wanted to build python in
Excel excel in Python uh so this is
Excel in Python you have a spreadsheet
you have dependencies so you have a data
frame on the top you have two images at
the
bottom um that one is done with pandas
this one is done with mat plit M Matt
plot lip who came up with that name mat
plot lip um so two pictures there and
it's a dependency graph this is how I
think about these kinds
of yeah uh numerical problems the the
notebooks have an advantage if you want
to tell a story but it's a very linear
story and it goes in one direction and
all like from top down here I wanted to
decouple that that sort of limitation
that you have in presenting your story
and make it uh yeah be placed
anywhere so here's a quick uh recording
of it so you can see um I have some
dependencies it's starting up the worker
it's sending a request to the worker to
execute and then um it proceeds on you
can analyze like how long it takes to
start up you can see when each re worker
receives an event so I'll zoom in a bit
on
this and this one comes with ltk so if
you explore ltk you clone it and you
write your own application on top you
can do similar analysis like
this
and here I see a problem right so I say
like it sends me the result for cell 32
32 and 32 so I see this three times and
I really didn't expect that so this is
helping me as a developer to uh make my
application more performant by using
like observability like debugging
doesn't really help in these kinds of
situations I can set a
breakpoint um but I have to know what
the problem is already where to set the
breakpoint I can do print statements but
print statements are yeah they don't
scale really well for this kind of
complexity so I'm trying to build some
yeah visualization tools that show you
the internals by observing what's going
on and showing you what's happening this
is another app that I built this is a
profiler uh this is also run in py
script so this is a visual view of the
execution of a particular exec of a
particular python application but the
whole UI is also done in py script so it
runs in Python it's the visualization is
also done in
Python and that one I did because I
could I wanted to show that it was
possible to do this but I got like
really convinced that yeah this is a
really viable platform for building Rich
client applications in the
browser uh this one can also explain by
just looking at the log of the
application um what it probably does so
I use jet GPT for that I just send the
log I said this one calls this one this
one calls this one this one what can you
make like what can you tell me about
this and it it it came up with things
like the UT UCT node is responsible for
the Monte Carlo Tre search algorithm and
then I look back in the source and
there's no mention of Monte Carlo so it
was actually quite surprising that it
came up with this kind of insight from
just the log statements
so so this is a this is an explanation
tool it's not really a profiling tool
because it tries to explain what the
design is in your application you can
see all the events that are happening so
this is more like an observability tool
again it's an example built on top of
biscript it does not use ltk so you can
take a look at it it's also open source
so you can just look at the source how
it's
implemented so summarizing you can
use python in py script and run very
interesting applications if you want to
see any live
examples uh and the startup times
there's a link to the top which is my
personal page and there's direct links
to uh the individual uh examples they it
works much better than doing live demos
here and I see we have six minutes left
if there are no questions I can actually
run the demos but then
uh um I guess there might be questions
so if you're interested in deploying
your data analytics applications to your
customers without requiring them to
install python first um and deploy them
through the browser just as a static
website biscript is really what you want
to try out and you can leverage ltk that
will get you going much faster and I'd
love to work with you on that um like I
said it's open source Apache license
so um go try it out and get inspiration
from the other ones so are there any
questions on any of
this question in the back yeah we have a
microphone
Runner yes thanks for your talk I was
just wondering the uh yeah the graphical
interface we saw they all look a bit
like 2000s early 2000s do you need to
know like CSS and all that kind of stuff
to make it look more fancy or is there a
more easy way so um that's very nice
comp ment thank
you so I'm not a designer I'm an
engineer that shows right so all my uis
that that's my colleagues always joke
about that uh I'm not a designer so this
is normally when you write a web
application you have people that have
experience with usability and they are
artistic and they know color pallets and
whatever um and this is done through CSS
yes so
um you you can set the CSS directly on
the widgets but you probably want to set
a a class a class on it and then have a
designer come up with the real uh
correct spacing and
whatever so I'm not trying to solve
the um yeah the design part of the the
problem that like python tries
to like like Leverage The technologies
that are underneath it rather than
reinvent things so I didn't want to
reinvent you do event handling I didn't
want to reinvent how you um how you do
styling but I did want to reinvent how
you actually construct the page and
that's what I focused on yeah it's a
good observation
yeah anym otherwise I'll just very
quickly show you what it looks like uh
I'm going to sit down for a second oh
there is a question yeah sorry I missed
that yeah um thanks for uh showing the
examples it's a nice to to get a feeling
for what you can do with python in the
browser but I was wondering um if you're
coming from the other side like if
you're front end developer in in the
JavaScript worlds would it also make
sense to learn about P
scripts um I I think less so because uh
the goal of py script is to
Leverage The Python ecosystem and the
abilities that you have to do uh data
analytics in the python stack and to
give you a different
rendering platform for yeah the outcome
of that
application um it's a catchup race with
JavaScript some people say like when
they advertise This and like if you go
to YouTube and you say py script it'll
say pscript5.dll
and there are plenty of rendering
Technologies on top of JavaScript that
are going to be hard to unlearn and and
replace with python so that's not the
main goal it's not to win over
JavaScript developers and make them
become python developers it's more for
um people that have python experience
like data analysts or data scientists or
Engineers that want to have a different
service for rendering their
uis so if you go to my personal site
chris.com there's a link to ltk so I'll
click on that and this is on GitHub
pages so we see the first time that I
load it um it's um it's saying like
0.964 seconds and that's because the
memory cache of the browser still has to
fill up uh but if I run it fast if I run
it again you can see that uh it comes up
faster and faster so now the caches are
built up in the
browser and this number that you're
seeing at the top right is the time it
takes to start up the python runtime
inside the browser so this runs on top
of web assembly this this number
includes loading this page figuring out
oh you you want to run biscript in it oh
and which one oh micropython okay let's
start it up and then it comes back and
runs my logic then I have to construct
this page and then I say that took like
millisecs so this is on micropython um
there's a lot of things you can do it's
a subset of the Python language so some
of the
library uh are cut in half so you only
have half of the features but uh things
like for instance reflection isn't there
so you can't ask a method like what is
your doc string because micropython says
like well I'm running on embedded
devices who need doc strings right so it
it removed those so if you want to see
those then you have to run on a real
python VM like C
Python and then you can actually see the
do strings so if I go to the dock
strings uh I can now see the do strings
for all these elements that I
have so the price we pay for this it's
longer startup time you can see uh when
I refresh this
page we're looking at whites space right
we're looking at a a loader so normally
you would have like animations here to
to fill up this time and hide it from
the
user but there yeah there's only so far
that you can make this look fast um so
that's why we can combine these two
things
and that's uh the spreadsheet
example so what we have here is
micropython running the
UI so I'll click on the bike store so
micropython is starting up and it's
starting up again in like 132
milliseconds then it run my page my page
is a little bit more complex in this
case so it has to go back to the
database retrieve like the the structure
of this spreadsheet and then render
it and that takes a little bit longer
but if you look at the
bottom the Beeper there's a
beeper is it out of time oh I would have
like expected a beeper like five minutes
before anyway so I'll wrap up uh so you
can see that uh micropython is starting
up um in about zero .1 second because
this is like the first kind of thing I
can do in my python logic so that's
about uh yeah 100 milliseconds then
after around a second I'm done with
rendering the
UI and in the meantime the worker has
started on a background thread so this
is using web workers like standard
JavaScript
workers and you can see that takes a
little bit longer so the pite startup
takes a bit while and building the whole
environment pretty loading pandas and
met plot lip but from that moment on I
can send work to that worker and not
slow down the like the UI at
all um because in a web application you
also don't want to run anything on the
main thread because that will hurt sort
of interactivity in your application as
well so I'll make a change here so this
is now 55 I'll make this 500 to make it
show up really well and then go back to
my
chart so we in the bottom we can see the
the
workers
getting requests to do something and
then sending back
results um so
my data frame changed and the
dependencies which are the images also
Chang so now the bike store is making Mo
most of its money from selling air which
is what we
expect and if you
I'll make it a little bit smaller so you
can see the structure and height the
logger here so this is what the UI
normally looks
like and Chris we really need to now
we're really into this
yeah so hopefully you've seen like uh
it's possible to
write um yeah professionally looking
even though the styling needs to be
fixed uh professionally looking
applications that start up really fast
in Python using pandas and non-plot lip
met plot lip uh and they start up within
a second right so this is like the
golden Mark that we had for Google
Sheets that I established at the
beginning so if you're interested in
this go to Chris la.com click on ltk and
build something I'd like to see that
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you